لنا واليها طي جنوبي تركيا ارتفاع ضحايا
الزلزلين الذين ضربا الولايه مساء امس الى
سته قتله ونحو 300 جريح وافادت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه بان زلزلين بقوه
6 درجات واربعه من عشره وخمس درجات
وثمانيه من عشره على مقياس
ضربا مركز منطقتي دفنه وسمندغ فيها تاي
الجنوبيه البلاد مساء امس الاثنين واضافت
اداره الكوارث انه تم تسجيل 32 هزه
ارتداديه بعد الزلزالين واضافت ان سكان
مدن هاتاي واغازي عنتاب ومرسين واضن
وانطاليا وكرمان مراش شعروا بالزلزل وقد
شعر سكان عشر دول بينها سوريا ولبنان
والاردن وفلسطين بالزلزالين
هذا واخرجت فرق البحث والانقاذ صباح اليوم
ثلاثه مواطنين فئتي جنوبيه تركيا من تحت
الانقاض توفوا خلال محاولاتهم اخراج اغراض
لهم من منزلهم المتضرر من الزلزال السابق
واعلنت بلديه اتاي انهيار مباني عده وجزء
من مبنى البلديه جراء الزلزلين
معنا من غزه عنتاب مراسل الجزيره منتصر
ابو نبوت منتصر كيف كيف هو حال سكان غازي
عنتاب في ضوء تكرار هذه الزلازل
حسن يعني هل غازي عنتاب كانوا قد شعروا
ببعض الامان خلال الايام الماضيه بالرغم
من الهزات الارتداديه التي لم تتوقف لكنها
كانت خفيفه ليله امس كانت يعني ليله مخيفه
ليلى
ظهر فيها الناس فهرعوا الى الشوارع والى
الساحات العامه والى الحدائق مره اخرى
بسياراتهم والى الخيام كانت الليله افضل
من الزلزال الاول الذي كان مفاجئا لوجود
الخيام ولوجود فرق الاغاثه وفرق الانقاذ
والدعم المستمر من السلطات المحليه الذي
كان يعني على اثر الزلزال السابق اما
الزلزالين الذين ضرباء المنطقه ليله امس
تسببان بحاله هلع جديده وحاله فزع فهرع
الى الشوارع كما ذكرت
والجميع تقريبا جميع سكان غاز عنتاب ناموا
في الشوارع وفي الساحات العامه وفي
الطرقات بعيده عن الابنيه السلطات المحليه
قالت ان مبنى واحد فقط الذي سقط نتيجه هذا
الزلزال ليله امس وكان مهجورا لانه كان
ضمن المباني التي وسمت من السلطات المحليه
بانها مباني خطره السلطات المحليه كانت
طوال الفتره الماضيه تقوم برصد الابنيه
ودراسه
الكفاءه هذه الامنيه وتحديد ما اذا كان
الصالحه للسكن وحددت اكثر من 9500 بناء
طابقي سيتم هدمها في الولايه من بين هذه
الابنيه هو هذا البناء الذي هدم وكان
مهجورا لا يوجد اي اصابات وقد طمنت
السلطات المحليه للاهالي وقالت ان الاشخاص
الذين وصفت مبانيهم بالاضرار الخفيفه
يمكنهم العوده الى بيوتهم بشرط ان ياخذوا
ان ياخذوا الحيطه والحذر هذا الامر لم يكن
يعني لم يفرق مع الناس كثيرا فبقيوا في
الشوارع هنا في المخيم الذي نحن نتواجد
فيه شاهدنا عدد من العائلات تخرج من هذه
الخيام الكثير من العائلات استقبلت عائلات
اخرى من اقاربهم عاشوا معهم في هذه الليله
شاهدنا بعض العائلات تاخذ يعني البطانيات
بعض الاشياء الاساسيه للتجاوبها في ليله
امس ليباتوا في هذا المخيم وايضا منهم من
شاهدناه وهم في السيارات وفي الحدائق وفي
الساحات العامه نشاهد هنا هذا يعني جانب
من الاوضاع في المخيم
الناس هنا استقروا هؤلاء اغلبهم بيوتهم قد
دمرت سابقا لكنهم استقبلوا ليله امس اقارب
لهم في هذه الخيام لا توجد خيمه لا يوجد
فيها اي يعني لا توجد اي يعني لا يوجد
فيها عائله او عائلتين نامت في هذه الخيام
ايضا الدرجه الطمانينه التي وصلت الناس
انهم بالقرب من هنالك مخيم اخر هذا المخيم
كنا قد رصدنا يعني رصدنه على مدى عشره
ايام خلال ليله امس عندما شاهدنا المخ
وجدنا ان ثلاثه عشره خيمه قد ازيلت من هذا
المخيم الاهالي قاموا بتسليمها وقاموا
بترك هذه الخيام لانه شعروا بالامان
والطمانينه والحياه كانت قد بدات تعود الى
ولايه غازي عنتاب وبدات الناس تعود
الاعمالها المواصلات العامه بدات بالعمل
كل شيء كان طبيعيا الى ان جاء هذا الزلزال
اليوم عاده الحياه الى طبيعتها وعاده
الامور الى نصابها في يعني ولايه غازي
عنتاب في المدينه صباح هذا اليوم والناس
بداوا يعودون الى منازلهم بحكم ان في
النهار يكون الوضع يعني ضمن السيطره
ويمكنهم يعني الهرب في حال كان هنالك جزاء
على العكس الليل الذي يكون اكثر خطوره
بالنسبه للناس لانهم يكونون نائمين شكرا